here we are hardrock what's your first
impression so far totally blown away
secret story for you I actually worked
here on the construction part of this
when I was like six months before the
show I was working for like $400 a week
I do a construction as an intern just
like learning learning learning and we
was trying to change the flavor football
and that didn't work out but I learned a
lot while I was working here about you
know construction about everything and
now I'm actually here for this event
which is like a total 180 from what I
was doing so I said chili an honor to be
here right now full circle moment full
circle so it's crazy life's going well
for you right now
yeah I've been working there doing this
yeah that's pretty cool
ingress doing modeling pursuing modeling
a lot of other things right now a lot of
other things like some other ladies by
chance are you put your current status
so you get single yeah you know get
there slowly it's not sorry at all but
yeah I'm single and but everything's
good though I'm not really focused on
dating right now
with me myself and trying to focus on
that right now exactly hit me when it
hits me my dad said they'll stop you in
the face
waiting for that will be a moment what
are you no but we could put it out there
for our viewers that he'd say you know
maybe just helping you out what are you
looking for them and that special
someone that one thing is just saying I
believe in it says through love someone
if someone who's willing to serve like I
am and to take care of other people and
share their love with everyone else man
here now Peter he's also a good guy he's
in a Peter Peters the man he's got a bit
of a tough go though he's been sick he
hit his head I mean the list goes on and
on if they asked you to step in and be a
backup he doesn't need a backup there's
no one like there's no one like Peter so
I couldn't even fill those shoes he's
the man where you asked to be the
bachelor we got to talks about it
something that you would be willing to
do maybe down the road right now my
heart really wasn't in a de la salon
back home and so I wasn't where I needed
to be right now but down the
who knows are you still watching Dancing
with the Stars I still have a TV
we got to help you out let me know but
no I don't have a TV yet so I haven't
been able to do I don't have furniture
cell phone guys yeah so I've been
watching snippets through Twitter and
all that I hope she wins that was it the
Mirrorball win in the roads this time
it's the mirror ball up so I mean you
know we could facilitate something if
you guys wanted to catch up again in the
near future
have you we're just we're just friends
right now and she's busy doing her thing
I'm busy doing my so but I mean she's
doing incredible dancing right now and
I'm so happy for she seems very happy
and it's fun to watch her a killer
[Music]